all right so the media's hatred of
President Trump is once again on full
display just listen to this it feels
like we've reached a level of crazy in
this White House and it's difficult to
take take it anymore
reality TV appearances tabloid gossip
conspiracy theories name-calling
vulgarities and a level of ego mania few
have ever seen in Washington and that's
saying something
it's like we're living inside a parody
from three years ago
consider what would happen if Donald
Trump became president the president
runs his old office like a reality show
he tweets like it's a reality show his
actions many of his actions are like a
reality show by the way Chuck Todd he
claims to be a hard-news unbiased
objective journalist but that's not all
remember how the media reacted a
president Trump's idea of having a
military parade let's see how many award
ceremonies are there out there in
Hollywood take a look at this insanity
that's right Trump wants a military
parade so you're just going full
dictator now just wasn't enough I guess
he wants his toy soldiers to march in
front of him in line in lockstep some
said it would put us in the same
category as folks like Russia North
Korean leaders where they love a
military parade the idea that we have to
look like Red Square is just absurd
maybe the answer Joe is to just get
Donald Trump a military uniform with
epaulets on the shoulders and give them
some salad dressing to put on the left
lapel and let them March around all
right I said it before I'll say it again
the left wing destroy Trump media is
missing the biggest story of their lives
here with reaction former White House
press secretary Sean Spicer and the
hills Joe conscious you know you go back
and you actually see that this wouldn't
be the first time Sean oh FDR the
beloved FDR had this happened and
eisenhower had something similar and
let's see JFK
not a full display but they they had
their own displays and then I think of
every Hollywood awards ceremony every
music ceremony but we can't have
an honoring parade of the military
really why is that so hard well I got a
couple things were interesting one is if
everyone everyone jump to the immediate
conclusion of associating with a
dictator as opposed to somebody who
actually loves and respects the military
and wants to honor them for their
service it's amazing I thought of the
people that you played that clip with
and maybe I'm wrong so I apologize if I
am but I don't think a single one of
them has ever served and I think it's
funny that when you have a president who
respects and honors law enforcement
first responders in the military and
says I'd like to have a parade to
showcase them to the American people
that somehow a negative thing less than
1% of the American people have served in
the military these days and we feel more
and more connected from those who do and
those who deploy every day to go protect
our freedom and when you have a
president who wants to honor them and
show the respect that they deserve and
maybe make them a little closer to the
other Americans that haven't haven't
been able to meet someone who has served
before I think that's a positive thing
for our country and to see so many
members of the media immediately jump to
negative conclusions somebody really
shows how disconnected they are not just
to the military but to what's going on
in this country it's like the time for
honoring themselves in Hollywood will
soon come to an end just just hold that
writ Sean Duhon in contrast when the
president decided not to go to the White
House Correspondents Dinner it was a
national tragedy he was disrespecting
the First Amendment oh it was the end of
the earth iakh apocalypse is coming but
when he wants to have a parade to honor
the military by god that's horrible you
know you think about it I added up it
was something like 25 30 between the
music industry and the Academy Awards
the global awards this awards Joe concha
I think it's actually a great idea and I
think the country we we owe them a debt
of gratitude and any way to honor them I
think is well worth it I think because
President Trump's name is involved in
this proposal Sean that that is causing
the reaction and you could play a game
of PU it's called parallel universe
where you take the name Trump out and
you put in a name like Chuck Schumer and
what if Chuck Schumer had actually
proposed a military Pro that's right he
did in 2014 and there
wasn't a sniff of outrage around that
but but to one point though you could
honor the military with the parade no
problem the costs are down logistical II
could pull it off no problem but I think
also the president really could back up
those words and back up a parade by
actually going to Afghanistan and
visiting the troops he hasn't done that
yet and I think that would go a long way
in showing that he's just not doing this
for show as his critics are charging
well I think that'll all happen but even
if he does that I'm sure we'll be
criticized how did they miss the biggest
story of their lifetime joke contra the
rest of the media how did they get it so
wrong on Trump Russia collusion well
have they got it wrong I mean I believe
the investigation is still going we
shouldn't get ahead of ourselves I know
is there any evidence that over a year
that you've seen no there hasn't been
any evidence presented and remember
everything gets leaked these days so if
they did have something it probably
would end up in the hands of The
Washington Post in The New York Times so
no not yet but let Muller finish this
investigation before we start saying
that there isn't any I mean they sort
through what we learned just in the last
week with the new Ness memo and the
unredacted Grassley grab memo Sean
Spicer seems to me that this whole thing
was a witch hunt from the get-go well
we'll see III want the investigation to
play only because I do believe that the
president's is very clear from the
beginning everyone involved in the
campaign there was no collusion so at
some point you you run out the clock and
you say as you've noted that if you
haven't found anything by now let's give
it a break I think that the stuff that
they found people for in terms of lying
to them and fara are are obviously
violations of the law and those people
should be prosecuted but the underlying
premise of this whole thing that there
was collusion for Russia as you pointed
out and Jo corroborated there's been
nothing so far I think we let this play
play out but I think that it's gonna be
interesting to see where the press goes
from there because what they were wrong
about the election they were so ready to
coronate Hillary Clinton they were all
crying election night and now that
they've wrapped themselves around this
axle we'll see where they go from there
will they admit that they were wrong
will they vindicate Trump or would they
move on to the next one because I have a
feeling that that's what's going to
happen how did they miss the stories
we've been talking about you
contract how did they miss the bulk of
the FISA warrant was predicated on
hillary bought and paid for lies how do
you miss that well sometimes there's
bias Sean where it's out in the open and
it's very clear that a reporter or an
anchor is is routing for a certain
outcome and then there's another kind of
bias and Sean knows all about this and
that's the bias of omission I mean when
when Sean was press secretary I'm sure
he was just stunned at the questions
that weren't asked of him at a press
briefing instead it was concentrating
solely on Russia so yeah I think that's
a very big story that isn't being
covered because they simply do not like
the narrative in these situations by the
way Sean congratulations you got a lot
of pep in your step
the Patriots lost and here you are
facing the fire okay thank you all